[Music]
hey guys thanks for joining
and let's wait for Chris to join me oh
we need to Chris just texted me and he
says what is either you just sent the
pictures are so blurry
what are they oh by the way I'm really
hungry like well don't we go to Koopa
the line is getting too long
cuz we need to focus I don't even know
what the purpose of this college the
subject line just said country travel
[Music]
I'm gonna try to text her to try to
reconnect so
so obviously as you can see virtual
communication could go really wrong if
you're not prepared I'm sure some of
those things might look familiar to some
of you in the audience and if being
humiliated like wanita isn't enough to
motivate you to work on your virtual
communication here's three other reasons
why it's important for you as GSB
students instructors business employees
business leaders first of all it's
valued by employees studies show that
over 80% of businesses today utilize
video conferencing for one-to-one
communication and over 76% of businesses
utilize them for team communication
that's something that's going to be very
broad in use second studies show that it
increases productivity by over 13% by
having flexible work work from home
policies that allow people to video a
video conference set for their job and
three I think this is the most important
part as Future Business Leaders is
growing and necessity every day 87% more
people in the global workforce today
utilize video conferencing than they did
two years ago and this is supposed to
accelerate over time so how do we do
better at our video conferencing there's
three main ways but three PSU gets
called plan product and presence first
it's important to make sure that you're
prepared before the meeting so that
you're able to be successful
second it's important to focus on your
product or content to make sure that
it's effective and engaging and third
it's always important to keep your keep
in mind your presence on group on camera
which can be even more important than
when you're face-to-face so to begin
let's start with how you can work on
your plan as you saw I had not done
correctly
it is crucial to plan any sort of
communication especially your to
communication and that's three things
one be prepared to define clear roles
and responsibilities and three this but
have a plan you don't want to be the
person that you see in that picture
number one reason that future
communications fail it's due to the fact
of lack plan lack of planning so this is
why we recommend define identify the
clear topic that you want to set the
meaning for know your audience identify
who you want to who you want to attend
and also where they will be why is that
you have to take into account the time
zones as well as integration of the
meeting and finally have the appropriate
technical technology for the call this
technology would be if you made video if
you need audio or also if you need to
present any sort of communication define
roles don't fly solo
clearly I was flying solo in me I had to
be multiple roles at a time make sure
that to make the key to the meeting
engaging and have enough pro printful
have people define roles across the
people from your meeting and also define
responsibilities as you see in the book
that the exceptional presenter goes
viral by timothy jay kogen he defines it
recommends a few roles for the meetings
as an example the producer the person is
in charge of creating the slides
defining the agenda creating the meeting
secondly host the host and co-host this
is similar to a TV show was the one
facilitator the person in charge of
communicating the host and the audience
it could be through questions or
concerns tech support clearly we needed
that I was both tech support host
co-host but if we had a person in charge
of
support at first it would have been much
easier to communicate Chris Packham and
finally a reporter a person who's in
charge of taking into a hand of a
actions and meeting minutes vertical and
finally test and have autonomy make sure
everything works in the car the
technology the people but also have a
plan B in case technology doesn't work
which has happened to all of us in our
meeting it was clear that Chris had not
tested the bill in his first and I
hadn't said the correct email so
remember
planning is crucial at crucial crucial
base for clear and accurate a
communicate verbal communication having
a unique a relatable product is key to
the success of every business when
crafting your virtual communication keep
this in mind keep this mindset of well I
will share with you some simple steps to
make sure that your final product is
both engaging and effective first set an
agenda second make it hard to look away
and third and with next steps how many
times have you joined a virtual meeting
without or leo with little or no context
as regard the objective of the call we
just watch Erica battle with the country
travel so when we thought that too
Juanita's case she could have said that
the goal was still plan and
unforgettable yes the experience or
maybe she just wanted to minimize the
time spent planning the GST to make sure
that she fulfill her travel requirement
that she couldn't fulfill before because
of coronavirus you can also keep a tiger
in the background to make sure that you
hold yourself accountable make sure you
share an agenda and have timing for each
section tip number two
make a commitment and ask for a
commitment make a promise to keep your
presentation short as long as your
audience give your undivided attention
start with the unexpected you can share
a video clip or an audio clip that we
did today cite some significant
statistics or share a powerful vivid
story also avoid too much detail
remember that you can share the minutiae
later finally incorporate audience in
creative ways you can pose some trivia
questions making sure that the answer to
those questions are part of the content
of the presentation remember attention
spans are short as David pointed out
earlier well let me tell you that
attention spans are really really short
when you go finally and with next steps
aligned on firm clear follow-up plans do
you think that Erica craze or I left
well-equipped that meeting knowing what
we should do about the GSD planning well
put expectations in writing make sure
that you're clear on what are the next
steps who should be responsible and when
should deliverables be ready that way
your audience will make sure that they
understand exactly what they need to do
and also you have established public
accountability now that we've talked
about planning and the actual product of
the call let's talk about your presence
anytime that you appear on a screen you
are communicating nonverbal messages
what message do you want to send today
we're going to give you three tips about
how you can effectively have a strong
presence in virtual communications first
look like you're in the room second
exude confidence and enthusiasm and
finally use appropriate
first look like you're in the room as
you can see here Chris chose to be an
Arbuckle which may or may not be the
appropriate setting depending on the
meeting you may want to reserve a
breakout room if it's more formal of a
virtual call but it's also important to
frame your image naturally so you'll see
here that it goes from the top of his
head to about his chest area the ideal
place to position yourself in a virtual
call is actually from a few inches above
your head to just where the table or
desk meets you and that's because if I
was sitting across from you that's how I
would see you in person second very your
eye contact of course a little bit of an
exaggerated example but as you can see
your eye contact in any eye movements is
exaggerated if you are sitting very
close to the camera so again it's
important to be an appropriate distance
away so that you look more natural on
the video call in addition if I'm
sitting across from you in a coffee chat
and I'm staring directly into your eyes
the entire time you probably won't feel
comfortable so it's not natural to do
that in a video call either you should
of course look into the camera and make
eye contact but also feel free to vary
it throughout the call and then finally
dress appropriately again obviously an
exaggerated example but don't wear a
shower cap also be sure to dress
appropriately as if you were a gun in
the room for the meeting from your head
to your toe so if the doorbell rings you
don't want to get caught with your
pajama bottoms under your suit jacket
next exude confidence and enthusiasm if
you are not in the room your voice has
even more power related to your message
it's important that you let your
confidence and enthusiasm flow through
in order to hold the audience's
attention so what we saw here is that
once Juanita started to speak in a more
monotone voice saku was driven to
distractions on his phone instead she
could have spoken with more animation
she could have also made sure to speak
an appropriately high volume with lots
of clarity and then finally use
appropriate gestures similar to the eye
contact and the movement with that your
gestures are accentuated on a video call
since the image is within one frame also
if your hands get close to the actual
camera they're going to look very large
and proportion to your head and you can
see in the picture and again that does
not look natural we want to make you
look as natural as possible so be sure
to use natural hand gestures rather than
fidgeting that will help convey
confidence and also be sure to not put
them too close to the camera as you move
only use hand gestures that reinforce
your message at an appropriate distance
so before we open up for questions
there's three things that we want you to
take away the three P's you could call
them business school people make sure
you have an appropriate plan make sure
your product is effective and engaging
and keep it mind your presence even when
you're working remotely
[Music]